in a letter dues newborn daughter in
which he shares his hopes for the future
Mark Zuckerberg announced he'll be
giving away 99% of his Facebook stock
over the course of his life that's a lot
Zuckerberg is worth forty six point
eight billion according to the Bloomberg
billionaires index and all but about 1
billion of that is in Facebook stock
quick math that's about 45 billion for
the Chan Zuckerberg initiative to put
that in perspective that means the
initiative will have assets roughly
equal to those in the Bill and Melinda
Gates Foundation
unlike the Bill and Melinda Gates
Foundation it's actually structured as a
limited liability corporation and that
means Zuckerberg can invest in companies
or startups that he thinks could make
the world a better place now Zuckerberg
isn't going to become poor overnight
he's not going to give away more than 1
billion annually over the next three
years and that means he's going to
maintain control of Facebook for the
foreseeable future one person of his
Facebook stock today is worth four
hundred and fifty million dollars he
also has about a billion dollars in cash
and slightly less than two hundred
million dollars worth of real estate
shares of Facebook have grown a hundred
and eighty percent since they first
debuted on public exchanges in 2012 and
they could continue to grow ninety
percent of analysts currently think they
will and that could mean more funds for
the future beneficiaries of Zuckerberg
philanthropy
you